hey everybody its Eddie Pepitone and
welcome to pep talks first time in a
studio in a while I've been on the road
which is like being in war and I'm here
with my with a good friend of mine and I
say good friend in the Hollywood sense
we don't see each other um but we do
respect each other in certain ways but i
want to say i want to so this is the
first time i've been talking with a
guest I've been doing little communicate
on my iPhone and now I'm in a studio I
want to just give you some of my dates
before I introduce my very profound
guest he's got a lot to say on a lot of
topics and this is where I'm going to be
and by the way I already feel like
you're judging me and I know I talked
about this a lot but because of the
tenor of my voice like it takes me a
while to get into the podcast and I
already feel like you people are like ah
i'm gonna i'm gonna switch over to Pete
Holmes or whatever the [ __ ] you to
listen to you people listen to oh yeah
let me listen to Pete Holmes he really
is in depth about things you know what
just go [ __ ] yourselves that's all I
want to say los angeles i am bringing my
new show and i'm calling it welcome home
to welcome home to the hollywood improv
the lab space monday februari 15th so
come to that februari 15th at 8pm our
tickets are only eight dollars i'll be
doing a longer set which is about 45
minutes Matt Dwyer will be joining me
I'll also have a show at cinefamily on
februari 17th as part of their show and
tell series i'll be showing clips of my
work as well as performances that i
enjoy and inspire me and I know what
you're thinking now Eddie you're just
reading from something and it doesn't
sound spontaneous and again I I beg you
to go to Pete Holmes tickets tickets for
the Senate family show will be available
at cinefamily dot org and that's cin e
i'll let you figure out the rest i'll be
also at the improv headlining field
at low show on 9 30 at the improv the
main room and then i'll be in vancouver
at the comedy mix on februari 25th as
part of just for laughs Northwest and if
you haven't heard I am a contributor on
a Nerdist podcast called will you accept
this rose where I bash the [ __ ] out of
the bachelor for people who watch that
all right this week's guest here we go
enough for me enough of that [ __ ]
opening that's read from a thing and you
don't really get me or him this week's
guess is a comic and a filmmaker you
know him from the comedy film nerds
podcast he's working on the movie
earbuds which he's going to tell us
about he's the co-creator of the LA pod
festival which is an amazing podcast
festival every year please welcome
Graham Elwood i would encourage
everybody to switch over to this
juncture let's i don't know why i picked
pete i guess because you know sometimes
when I hate different comics you know in
the business mm-hmm i I just I just go
from different guys you know or gals and
Pete lately has been on that list like
[ __ ] him you know I mean yeah why not
why not he's never done the LA pod fest
oh yes it will really [ __ ] you're his
agent in Ganga oh yeah you like I have
to go to his agent yeah I don't have to
go through marc maron's agent he
interviewed the president who the [ __ ]
were young table come back when you get
Putin on your [ __ ] docket and then
how about that all right the Putin I I
that would be a get to get like we've
been trying to get in for comedy film we
want to do a magic mike a spoiler app
with Putin and that sort of i think is
Magic Mike again Magic Mike is the male
stripper movie Oh Winnie Tatum Channing
Tatum big group and they did a second
one good yeah so you do you and Chris
yeah Chris Mancini is your is your co
guy on a comedy film there prefer
co-host co-host
let's touch let's not change the
industry standards all of a sudden
Edward just you recall about you know
because you know I've been a guest I've
been a guest and you guys watch all of
the movies man you watch watch them all
now I now so let's talk a little movies
now this is right in your wheelhouse
because this time it's so funny because
the last couple times uh oh I went once
or twice that I've been on your show I I
just didn't see any movies and I was
going up there bullshitting that I saw
them but yeah I've seen a lot of movies
lately um I've seen a lot of movies
lately because I get all these screeners
you right and so I've come caught up on
the movies what's your favorite movie in
this Oscar season let's talk about that
for a second um well obviously I'm
really happy the Oscars are all white I
think get America back on track hahaha
Trump style oh let me tell you something
live i was elected there won't be one
person of color and the Oscars by the
way what's this deal with Chris Rock
hosting it is that a big [ __ ] joke
anyway Iowa we love you I lost I lost
but I want to say this I love you very
much for helping me lose thank you um
yeah Trump's good people I i I'm gonna
buy a farm he said that in his
concession speech you know what I love
this place so much I'm gonna buy a farm
and I'm gonna kick the people out of
that farm who lived on that land cuz
they're poor because the ball yeah I
it's so great that Bernie Sanders is the
only guy he's not a Christian and yet
he's the only guy trying to help poor
people so I uh back to your Oscar a shot
the Christians right about here hail
hail wonder if that makes comedy film
nerds yeah it's why I love being guess
cuz I can't you know can we don't talk a
lot of politics and movies but no they
oscars at the movie i think is is is
really good yeah is uh the revenants and
really good movie a spotlight is amazing
spotlight you know it's interesting spot
line in revenant now the only difference
in those family films well bring the
kids the boat fit well the church
certainly is all about fit the Catholic
Church I mean they really got to know
family they have kids they gay love kids
and by the way folks yes that was kind
of a you know a shot you know I'm not
trying I'm not trying to solve shoe or
soft pedal molestation at all I'm just
here with the guy who seems to want to
make fun of everything i have no point
in wow well but um the only ones between
those two movies are the bear right like
David bear in the revenant and there's
no [ __ ] bad yeah yeah they don't jump
Anene I mean funny the guy who really is
if I wake on news just a social [ __ ]
right all right now as far as that
lately he has no discernment or subtlety
like as far as I could see the only
difference between spotlight and
revenant is there's no bad so bad right
like spotlight haven't had a bear and be
a lot better huh at least at least at
some point during spotlight they should
have been at least like a wolf or a
jackal oh and now I feel all I just for
a second I was like oh I thought I was
on the road doing morning radio
sometimes terrifying I don't like movies
with subtitles all right coming up next
broads are they stupid where Ella 1035
good particular do like do you do some
of those horrible are morning radio
things it's not my guys so far that I
have done I just did one in my tree all
not to brag cosmopolitan city out of the
country right on they were pretty cool
they doesn't know that it's true it's to
be it to be fair some of them some of
them are really cool
was it like that there's precedent
Stephen Philly those guys are really
cool others bj Shea in Seattle it does a
pretty good I've been on some that that
that do cool their front shows they are
and as others that are like doing that
other kind of show that other stuff
which is just like there's not as many
of many more and of course yeah they've
got they how come those having the
country's dumber hahahaha I think the
main same people who watch mainstream
media true that's right podcasting is
better pricing is making people smarter
making people more open-minded that's
true but the mainstream I think there's
still so many more of those people or is
that not true well hopefully they're
gonna start killing and eating each
other that's what they want to do they
want they want society to collapse they
can't wait for it just and they're like
oh you never gone and you don't have
canned food they [ __ ] can't wait
they're gonna start this funny i posted
i said when society collapses Trump
Palin supporters are gonna be the first
ones to start raping and killing and I
have a cousin this is going to be a
shocker in Idaho who writes and and all
these people posted like out there they
were all making other jokes and he goes
man why he's like I don't understand all
the hate we should understand people
more we shouldn't be dividing and I
wrote him and I said his name is Jay I
go so Jim so me did I go Trump is like
the he is the super bowl MVP of dividing
and hatred so I'm gonna make fun of him
to the best of my ability and all of his
supporters yeah like Robert Gates former
secretary of defense for Bush and Obama
a Republican for sure Rodan are a little
bit of a Republican wrote an article
saying if Trump gets he was interviewed
in an article and he said if I if Trump
gets elected I'm emigrating to Canada
did he [ __ ] say this is a right-wing
this is a rope this is a Reagan
Republican like he was in the Reagan
administration he was in Bush he's a
he's a Republican make no mo bones about
it was like [ __ ] this guy yeah yeah so
it is [ __ ] there they're out of their
minds dude what's going on this is my
two cents and it's
not an original thought like all my
thoughts but there's a lot of
disenfranchised people out there
economically which Sanders is speaking
to and those disenfranchised people
economically they latch on to guys like
Trump yeah because they just you know
they just want to feel powerful and
Trump is all about this foe and that's F
aux that's a French word folks I watch a
lot of cooking show hahaha and uh and
independent small indie movies unlike
Ram who watches the big Hollywood
blockbusters and today we're doing Panda
3 what the [ __ ] is that but anyway these
peoples good movie they latch on the
guys like Trump because they're so
[ __ ] they're poor yeah there I mean
there's two kinds of the people latch on
the Trump I think it's mostly the
disenfranchised people who who are like
so powerless and then they're really
insanely right powerful people who just
who just want to Hitler 'ish Hitler s
well the thing that's so mind-boggling
to me is you you're that so your poor
your blue collar and you've been laid
off and the factory jobs are gone or
whatever and it's tough for you okay I
get that now you think a guy that flies
in a helicopter gives a [ __ ] you were
laid off because of guys like that right
out sourced your jobs like how do you an
icy because what happens is guys like
Trump and those right-wing guys Reagan
did it too is that they wrapped
themselves in the flat yeah yeah you
know they wrap themselves in a flag and
God and that's what these these people
go to you know the flag which is so
funny cuz the founding fathers many of
them were like well let's eat go easy on
the God like Jack you know like we came
here because you know we want to be
freed him not we were persecuted or like
as Benjamin Franklin said religion is
the opiate of the masses Benjamin
Franklin said that he's on the
hundred-dollar bill yo um so I thought
karma
said that are you sure it's Ben Franklin
up I'm right yeah it's Karl Marx don't
worry look at that closer nuts marks and
franklin had a lot in common the only
well they both like kites I were gonna
say that the only difference was the
kite like the only difference your buddy
Franklin said that now it was marks but
the opiate of the people I is religion
I'm gonna stick with Benny he also said
get the ball fight oh I did you know
that mark said that we had a dog for a
while and he was like get it get the
ball that was marks haha when he threw
the ball to his dog marks was always
like get it get the ball as Mark you yet
according to what let's not have a
competition huh Oh who goes never wrong
hahahaha oh you know what it's not a
competition but we both agree on on the
politics what kind of undermines my
point but anyway thee no no your point
is we've taken that the founding fathers
were like you know it's let's step back
on right a religion stuff but the
demagogues and but Trump now he already
lost that first primary right which came
out of the blue so it would be fun to
see him just go down in flames because
he is this guy who like I couldn't like
he's been saying he comes off like a
wrestler doesn't like like his whole
thing is like oh really you if I was
president I would tell China to where to
stick it that's what I will help China
oh really no China that own sixty
percent of our debt you're gonna roll in
there I'm Donald Trump and they're gonna
go have you ever dealt with the Chinese
probably not they're gonna just go oh we
always used to say whenever anyone said
to me of your adult with Chinese he goes
I do business in China I do plenty of
business in China I went back bankrupt
in China a couple yeah yeah I think it's
just funny how he purports to be this
incredible businessman and he's been
bankrupt about I don't know two or three
yeah already yeah he's bankrupted a
couple of companies I it's so funny to
me like how you I just don't understand
how you can't look at that guy go oh
he's be
he's full of [ __ ] like he's just full of
[ __ ] like I can look at Hilary Clinton
go she's got a little full of [ __ ] nuh
center absolutely i don't know i'm a big
fan of the clinton on the ship you i'd
love to see a female president is not
her rise i did the games and the bushes
have run the White House for the last 30
years yeah right exactly like Whitley
like like what are we to family what are
we a two-family country just like an
oligarchy that just did what we are in
oligarchy and that's what I love about
Sanders is that he just says it he just
comes right out and says it I just love
it yeah she would just be more and it's
so funny when I was watching Hilary give
her a little Iowa like victory speech
which really wasn't a victory I was just
so funny to see bill over her left
shoulder did you sleep now is it oh yeah
you gotta watch things other than movies
hahaha if collar with money if if you
guys just reviewed press conferences you
and Chris oh I threw that that be I
would love to do a live a live press
conference we got seven press
conferences where review in this this
week one is not how about the California
gas leak what do you think of that
[ __ ] thing nobody talks about this by
the way they're saying it's this is just
we're gonna be all over the place
because I have a DD but the I want to
get back to revit Ross like babies
anymore he'll get rid of that liberal
problem immediately Trump 16 but um and
we'll also talk about the morning in all
seriousness you should buy a gun because
then you can defend yourself against the
a.d.d do you deserve it i'm set they got
a TD can't attack you no one's taking my
gun away because I'm scattered oh cuz he
good scanty you didn't get that for a
second it was nice that what that was
folks I is it was a little a theater of
the mind guys oh sorry I cut you off hey
ray Elliot died today I thought what
we're talking about something else we we
we have a lot of threads in here you a
lot of thread of gas leak the ghastly
okay here's what I thought talk about a
gas rest in peace half a bob
ray though today ray Elliot you Bob and
Ray I don't know if you were fan of
those guys Bob and Ray oh yeah you just
Google and Bob and Ray like I think it's
50s they were really sixties I google
them at all i came up with karl marx
google's broken it's bob elliott ragel
Deena Bob Elliott Benjamin Franklin
killed them is this right do I have this
right okay basically this is how
knowledge now is disseminated right just
like that like hey Frank I think it was
there's a meme on facebook and yeah
that's a fact yeah Alyssa puts a pie
chart some political pie chart on
facebook i guess sixty-three percent of
this guy's didn't like the other thing
soon as it's in print right that's in
the interpreted brit that it's real so
go ahead what we say the gas leak I want
to talk about that because nobody
[ __ ] talks about its brew it's been
going on for months and it's so funny be
we're talking about by the way is that
there's a gas leak of methane that
exploded here in Los Angeles in a
community called porter ranch it was
like it became a twilight so that
community how to evacuate animals were
dying and people were bleeding out of
the ER the eyes right but the gas
company says it's not that bad hahaha
that's why very well hello you've
reached Southern California gas if you
were bleeding out of your eyes plus one
yeah we have we have determined that
[ __ ] I just saw him on the news like a
week ago and I was like a spokesman for
the gas company and it's just like this
is what drives my folks this is what
drives me nuts about mainstream media
and the TV so this guy then the media
goes oh ok well we covered all sides
shut the [ __ ] up reloj the gas company
said it wasn't a prop really your gas
like that's all sides it's all sides
this is like you have to just go the gas
company is lying there just just assume
they're lying the mainstream media is
beholding you know sure I'm bought and
paid for by these right I mean energy
companies are the biggest I think I
wonder if they're the bank's the oil
companies the natural gas companies they
they're the ones who owned us and the
insurance companies here
a fun thing to do hahaha yeah he's uh
anyway I loved revenant I can see
bridges pies good bill uh is uh I
cancelled my cable several years ago you
did I stopped I stopped watching and
then I just was doing Netflix and I had
digital antennas and digital antennas
talk to me a little bit about that it's
a revolution friend is high def channels
there's all these weird it's like it's
like ham radio there's all these weird
channels floating around out there that
you can just pick up so that was really
cool so then about a year ago of my time
warner cable which is evil well they're
evil if you like they're not that I mean
I don't know I mean I I kind of like a
shitty internet and the price keeps
going up and write for the customer
service I gotta be fair and balanced on
on them so they kept raising their rates
yeah raising it raising a trade wireless
through them yeah i just had Wi-Fi no no
yes while just just inside that's all I
call it wireless um who's on the
wireless head it's Franklin is it the
opiate thing the yard sit still is it
obviously is it a call back to that
factoid we won't let oh damn it why do
we get rid of that call back tell Marge
to try to get rid of the call no I mean
they're reaping in there what's going on
you got it okay alright folks what you
just heard by the way was nothing go
ahead um so uh I cancelled it and then
they kept raising the rates raising the
rates and so a verizon was like get fios
and they dare always jamming his bundle
so unda lit was like so it was like 60
bucks for just just internet with time
warner and 467 i could get cable and a
home phone which i never home phone what
am i 90 we have a home phone but which
by the way is basically a home phone
these days is basically means you get
recordings from people selling things
it's robots robots that's all it is I
just turned the ringer off yeah and
don't pay attention to it and give and
put the num
down in some sort of marketing survey
like we need a home phone sometimes I'll
pick it up and just let my anger out i
have free-floating hostility and i will
just just scream into the phone i have
i'm on a no-call list I'm calling the
police on you like I threaten them with
the police I just know he thinks that
may scare people because whenever I'm
threaten with the police I get
frightened you know yeah cuz I've told
you PS to shut when UPS now double parks
I don't know if people have this in
other cities but they double park and
there's a loud piercing beeping they
have that BP alleys when they leave
their blinkers on and I'm like excuse me
I went I told the guy who's
double-parked is truck I go the [ __ ] is
this high-pitched beeping are you trying
to kill me and my dogs and I always lie
and say I have a baby trying to sleep I
have no children I'll never have
children but i always say i have a baby
whenever i get into a hassle with any
kind of person I'm like I have a baby
asleep okay I don't need this [ __ ]
anywhere the deal better wear it I have
a baby I always feel like that carries
the most weight in society like if
there's a guy if I'm at a game Dodger
Stadium something a guy is standing up
in front of me I go I got a baby here
can you sit the [ __ ] down I have a baby
oh I'm sorry i sorry sir all right sorry
I didn't know you a father a young
father hey hey it was [ __ ] Benjamin
Franklin who said it I have a baby here
we don't talk about Karl Marx in front
of the baby Marge let's just stop the
car back then yeah let's just why don't
we just can we put an end to it in any
way possible gather Franklin call back
well look into it because it's really
bringing the show everybody's going over
the homes going over to olds if you
switch over to Pete Holmes right now
you're a trump person you're a trim
person um so I finally go to verizon and
and I like fine so they quote unquote
have faster internet here's the thing
about verizon it feels a little bit
faster one thing about verizon it
doesn't crap out at least once a month I
don't have to
reboot the whole file system at time
warner Yemm Warner is a bag of dicks I
know and by the way there that that
reboot thing is always like very
stressful because it may or may not
reboot right and it's always to god it's
it's never when you're just like sending
the light like a good wedding right yeah
I guess I was wrong about the marks
quote it's always something like I will
meet you friday in vancouver right or
whatever fax me this for you know email
payment information science exactly we
need the signature scan and copy and my
q 5 by 4 p.m. you know you're the
roasted deal that will enable me to
finally get a house will grow there so
i've got verizon so for the last year
I've been watching regular TV again and
i have I was without it for four or five
years and didn't miss it didn't miss it
it all the only reason I can't give it
up and this is my last hurdle with
corporate culture in general is I still
love my new york sports teams i still
like to watch football and the rangers
but i think i could do that on the
computer yeah that's the thing now that
the sports the sports leagues have wised
up because they're just like sick of
cable and directv the sports leagues are
all like hundred bucks a year you get
everything like every sports league just
about is doing that but we need [ __ ]
the internet so we have to go through
these idiots you right that's that
that's where they know they have a
monopoly yeah i bet they always bud the
like if you [ __ ] look look listen to me
they like [ __ ] their shite they're
like listen to me this is how they
should talk like DirecTV listen to me i
can but it's like in spotlight let's sit
in a bar where they owe ya Paul garboil
whatever I forget his name come Isley
and and Michael eNOS is how it goes Mike
guy lanes on a guy like that's how the
bundles go if you want to go just dinner
that's fine it's only 80 bucks a month
but for 60 you know what I mean I would
hate for your wife to find out like this
I some veiled threat you know I mean
would it be weird if the papers got a
hold of
as you were wasting twenty dollars just
for the end I mean I hate for that to
happen you know it's very bill it's just
like I hate break I hate for a guy to
fall down a flight of stairs because he
didn't bundle you know what I mean guys
fall down all the time it's bad they
just got the internet and everything's
crazy but they had a home phone the last
words you hear in your life is you
should have bundled yeah you should have
been the last word year before you get
thrown down yeah yeah you're in a trunk
plastic bag over your head yeah yeah so
so you don't want a bun the LA and
you're like a bundle you're hitting the
top of them yeah the trunk up on dog
yeah yeah so now your bundle azoulay
late that internet only is that
comfortable back there to internet only
in the back of a [ __ ] trunk you
[ __ ] mope um so that's what the
verizon guy said so do anyway i'm
watching the commercials and i had
forgotten like oh first of all I guess
I'm supposed to buy diamonds I'm
supposed to buy a lot of diamonds which
we all should do because they're mostly
made from slave labor haha like well I
have diamonds littered all over my house
oh yeah yeah yeah just because they when
the Sun hits of it's beautiful and
during Christmas boy if you didn't have
a car with a bow on it or the perfect
family you know what AM L your say
talking about it's just so yet sick and
then and then Nick the other thing too
it's like all these ads are geared it
like I guess housewives or something
like but got another dumb husband well
you know this products dumb husband
proof and it's always just so mobloc
boom a little italy the idea is you DVR
these shows you want to want right and
you just [ __ ] speed through that [ __ ]
but still if i'm watching games that i
want to watch well that's where they
know it because TV Live Sports is the
one place where that people are watching
actual commercials cuz you're probably
not gonna DVR a game well if it's some
big game I yeah yeah more than likely
you're not because but but like I'm
flipping through the channels and I'm
just like what Bravo what are you doing
like just become a gay bar haha like
just I'd like I haven't heard me of
nothing and then all these channels I
used to remember all my old discovery
now
oh the [ __ ] Hill people of alligator
town and whatever like yet discovery
yeah you're the size channels these
science channels have now gotten on
board with all this reality [ __ ]
like like everything has to be a
competition or something Horrible's
gonna happen to somebody like tuna and
when a tune in on the science channel
went planets collide or when planets
turn ugly you know what I mean or or
it's always some like family of awful
mutant people that we got to watch the
family of the like National Geographic
you know like my geo that used to be a
great chance right and now you're just
like what the [ __ ] and I'm sure they're
all like well the ratings I want to sit
yeah it's now to go the raid to Nielsen
rating system is the most byzantine RKA
still using yes yes it's just like do I
netflix is winning awards and kicking
all of your asses because they can tell
you exactly how many people watched
their thing exactly they can tell you
how many people tuned out is that right
they've day know when people drop it you
all that [ __ ] they've got all that right
and it's just like I was just watching
the SAG Awards all right now you don't
you know what that's a [ __ ] name drop
and that I was live to a hospital is
live tweeted at Graham Elwood trending
SAG Awards 2016 oh but anyway Netflix
was thanked like three or four times the
head of Netflix was thanked Ted Sarandos
uh who made um uh super high me he
helped make super high me with Doug
Benson movie also put my my DVD grandma
with live from Afghanistan on netflix
nice uh so he's all about cool creative
content Jeff Bezos was thanks and Amazon
like these arms getting fake now and
then the Oscars is just like some old
white country club that's like let's
invite all the old Whitey's from last
year did the Oscars it's as though and
Chris Rock is hosting it bad at which
that I can't wait because he was gonna
cause when the boycott started yeah he
was talking about leaving not hosting
and then he just say he got pressure to
not host and then he decided actually
I'm gonna stay in hose
so you think he might have some
interesting things I can't wait to see
it I can't wait to see it like I'm just
like he should you know I love to watch
man i love to watch Rick eager face he
that's the golden glow lambs all of the
celebs and it is so he [ __ ] funny he
started the golden globes by saying
because they were little noisy goes we
you this is the first thing he said they
go look we you shut up you you
pill-popping sexual degenerate
narcissist that's how he started he
slammed everybody it's like they they
all kind of IRA when he hosted it a
couple years ago and he was talking
about how because i'm on TV i'm not i
have a TV face and you know TV people
are uglier than movie people good so
goddamn funny he's great yeah i just
love him but I don't so that's why so
yes so it's a regulation so regular TV
you do just a bit like I just almost
like oh god yeah and there's so many
ways now to watch [ __ ] stuff they're
like you told me I'd never had a digital
antenna but people do the apple TV and I
have an actual TV yeah are those good i
love it i love my apple TV um cuz i can
watch netflix on it you can if you got
if you got a subscription to any of your
favorite sports leagues oh yeah you got
major league baseball i I do NHL I liked
hockey you got any child you could watch
it on your Apple TV you can watch it on
your iPhone you could watch it on it all
your device all your device is netflix
right you can yeah it sucks man I you
know it's but the flick the question is
and this is this is the dilemma which
they know they have us on minute
somebody comes up with like affordable
good high speed internet that's all
you're buying 30 bucks a month right
everyone will dump I mean people are
cutting cable anyway they're just saying
[ __ ] it you know I mean like they're
buying you could buy the hot spots and
put them in all your mind stuff like
that i'm not gonna do something like
that cuz i'm just like the hot spots do
they work yeah I don't know I'm gonna
talk to a tech okay you know that man
get a check here I know I know the tech
guys to check guys are the most
important [ __ ] guys
unless society collapses and only they
go where they gonna do I love that that
you talk about like that you know you
mention it that the these people waiting
they hope their way hoping for society
collapse cuz they're gonna be like
there's no more rules anymore you know
they just can't wait to kill but they
can't wait they can't wait and they're
all [ __ ] arm to the T to the teeth
they're just gonna where do they live
here ah there in between melrose I la
cienega in the Fairfax days it's a mile
yeah no miracle my Mara on miracle mile
they're all by the La Brea Tar Pits the
little underneath that start pretty
slick but a little bit a little bit back
to movies uh-uh you loved yeah you know
what's funny is that's watching these
[ __ ] screeners and it's on the road
so I only had my iPad so it was
ridiculous i guess to see the revenant
on an iPad right that's a movie I I'd
you see it would you see it on I they
had the watch a screener of it it was a
screener they was a live streaming
actually did it through my apple TV but
I you know so I have a decent flat
screen I've like a 47 also you put it
through your flight so yeah so sardonic
pretty decent that was decent but even
watching it at home and I turn the
lights off and everything I was like
yeah I part of me was like I should have
watched this on a big screen yeah
visually that movie is is stunning yeah
it was stunning on my iPhone yeah and
that what does that tell you if your
iPhone made it stunning imagine what a
giant screen would do you would you
would want to kill a bear need it hahaha
that movie was if you haven't seen that
movie is so dense don't like old lady
it's like so [ __ ] I know it's your just
like at one point I was watching I was
just like Jesus like what more does this
guy have to go through yeah and it never
ended and it reminded me of my life like
but a difference in a different setting
you know like I keep trying to climb
this comedy mountain and boom a guy
lately instead of RT its home so whoever
it is instead of Thomas Hardy what's his
name Tom RT yeah Tom Hardy was a good
villain it was a great actor he's a
really good actor yeah what else has he
done mr. Khamenei filleted Bane and dark
knight right oh now I hate it that was
your favorite
dark knight movie we have we have
different tastes i hated that thing
attached to his face I was like trike
control Eddie Pepitone take control of
your podcast you think the darkness is
your I was born molded bad I could I
could do bein all name I love bein um I
didn't know he was bein because i
remember in vain he just looked very cut
like physically cut but in this movie he
just looked he just looks like he's a
guy who spit a lot in a civil war outfit
she had a muffler on his face yeah yeah
but revenant spotlight was really good i
like i like a movie my favorite movie
last year was by the guy who made
Reverend what's his name the director no
wrong right now 100 area 2 or whatever
ya hear you to also he's Japanese he am
now I'm done wrinkles Oh japanese guy
hey guys I out downtown all right my
wife just saw Rickles I think he's like
87 now nice just saw Rickles in in
beverly hills do it do a set he has to
be helped on stage and he's hooked up to
tubes and [ __ ] but still just yeah he's
like a floating head now but he's really
he's like oh japanese guy in the back
can't deal with the floating head I
already was it's easy such a [ __ ]
alleged right but my fav movie last year
by you rot in erotic inner outer or
something yeah he was bird bird bird man
Birdman I was so [ __ ] happy for
Keaton I thought he was so [ __ ] funny
in that movie and the way that [ __ ]
movie went and i'm not a big head Norton
fan but he used Norton's so [ __ ] well
right in that movie and like the way I
was even into the play with in the movie
and almost like an inside joke cuz
Edward Norton has a reputation being
sort of difficult that he cares like
yeah he made him the difficult broadwell
celebrities by the way let me just do a
side an aside on celebrities
Bravo celebrities for you making fun of
yourselves like in other words if you're
difficult [ __ ] and then you play a
difficult [ __ ] on a show that doesn't
make you any better by the way you're
still a [ __ ] [ __ ] just because you
have a certain awareness because you've
been in therapy or maybe in a sweat
lodge maybe a few of you have come to
sweat watch your 8 figure income does it
make you know ball I just love all the
celebrities who poked fun at themselves
oh yes i know i'm a difficult [ __ ] so
brave it's so brave and revealing of me
yet on my very next project i'm gonna
treat the same people I've always
treated like like like [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it is funny like I loved her vases
extras and that was a funny [ __ ] show
yeah it's it's I don't think you can
ever and others ever of you know we
should ever get rid of making fun of
celebrities no no no I I'm just I'm just
poking fun I'd like to get crazy famous
just too me too just who the [ __ ] on
every [ __ ] that don't know why
I'm doing it's the wrong way no just to
be a gracious no I would definitely come
back at a few like if I got super super
famous which seems to be I told you know
I said to people if I'm not famous by 90
91 I'm out of this business but well
that's the big day or so into our
careers that it's just like what could I
do I've had that conversation I'm done
my [ __ ] taking a backpack and a
surfboard I'm going to Central America
and well you could do that because you
know how to surf and you seem like a guy
you know you've been over to Afghanistan
a few times you you see you've been with
the troops you seem like I could take
care of himself me I'd be dead like if I
went on the road without an itinerary in
my hand
and hotels lined up I think I'd be dead
quickly wait I would just be walking
around the streets of like Columbia
going is there a festival a comedy
festival is there a yuk yuk a bogota
funny bone is there is the medicine not
to me and in front of the Medellin
Cartel if they're still around and I'm
just in front of them going cocaine is
not correct the Medean cartels gone yeah
nobody does cocaine anymore drugs they
fix higher cocaine is big yeah that's a
big deal good you back another reason to
[ __ ] on Trump like we gotta put up a
wall oh yeah because what so we're
Americans gonna get their drugs since
we're the ones fueling all the violence
in Mexico and Central and South America
guess why why because our demand for
drugs yeah our demand O'Kane for coach
Wayne specifically is what's causing all
of this and that's basically just
Hollywood I would think yeah lard Miami
dislike this neighborhood specifically
this studio ed Norton's uh so all right
so he likes but we both like spotlight
to there was something spotlight now
Smyly was interesting move because it
wasn't really action-packed but it was
just a really good kind of out of how
you would describe it but just like
investigative drama and like I love and
then Ruffalo does Ruffalo Ruffalo revel
is so great and the thing to think
that's that I really liked about
spotlight obviously it's based on actual
events and actual people yeah so that
was good and I think they the the
director did a fairly good job of like
let's try to keep his accurate of this
as we can because the question is how
could this happen we all asked and that
movie shows you yeah the Catholic Church
controls that city all those reporters
are Irish Catholic they even people
within the paper there's times and let
go everyone says here so in the Catholic
you can't go out to the Catholic just
like it's just this foregone conclusion
and even like without getting into to
spoilers of it there stuff that happens
where is there a big cover-up and now it
was just sort of a institutionalized
look the
other way by everybody and and that's
the thing that why it's so good is is
easy it's all Irish Catholics where the
reporters like Rachel McAdams you know
her her Nana goes to church every day
right and it's like this the thing in
there that that that Mark Ruffalo's
character says he's a great job Michael
Keaton does a great job yeah that the
kind of tough editor yeah they all come
in with their mother money just goes
gimme more gimme the story get the fat I
don't know get out you know just and
it's like I love the way newspaper guys
who portrayed yeah for once I'd like to
see a newspaper guy portrayed like hi
Frankie let's get the top story who
feels like writing today I he just comes
in singing there's a leak in California
a big mess saintly new wants to cover
the truth I do and then cookies for
everyone who ever gets whoever can nail
the Catholic Church on molestation gets
a cookie this is a wheel in the office
let's run away um no but that's the
thing that's great about spot like to is
is they always ask these questions like
this is what many of the mast in the
movie which is this could have happened
to any of us yeah why resonate me with
person I was Irish a meijer castle are
you well not Catholic anymore because of
things like spotlight yeah but yeah I
was raised Irish Catholic I didn't know
you were and um you know it could happen
to me could happen to my brother could
happen any I mean where we did you go up
here grew up in Chicago quietly I've
lived in Wisconsin actually I would
lived in Madison Wisconsin tall is about
11 right we went to cat I imagine it
must have gone on there too they want a
six percent the number like they say in
the movies six percent of all priests
everywhere we're doing it there's no way
that yeah there's someone that I know it
didn't happen to and I don't I'm not
like I'm not aware of it but there's no
way like I you know so however they have
there's the Catholic Church are they
ever going to recover from that like
like well or do people still go they'd
still push that
I like like like a devout believe is
still will still go to Catholic Church
yeah I still have friends and then we're
going and my kids are going I'm just
like yeah I wouldn't let my kids near
that place but yeah I know everyone's
okay they pay reparations and they've
done this and that I said yeah because I
got caught and that's right second the
movie like hey Catholic Charities does a
lot of good it's like this is evil and
it it's why I was like uh you know they
pulled us that the greatest thing the
Catholic Church ever did was sort of
turn their back on my mom when my
parents got divorced because she was
raised Catholic and she was like you go
to the church for help and support yeah
and they said no if you get to push her
out of the church yeah nice and she was
like okay done pulled us out of Sunday
School ah I love it i'm glad and it was
like it was done yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
so I mean they would have been like oh
here's a couple of boys that are got
divorced parents and the moms work in
jobs and I mean maybe they would have
[ __ ] gone after my brother and I I
don't know oh yeah I mean six percent
yeah so it's not like one one-hundredth
of a percent severely so you know it's
like um I'm glad that movie was made
because it brings awareness to it which
is why I was so disappointed sought this
a lot on comedy film words you know that
I do have to plug the best we get it you
know I got a thing at kinda better
burgers ha ha ha me feel more calm so um
no II you can plug that yeah but like
little plug homes [ __ ] um but like
if you look at the Best Picture
nominations which is there's there's no
movies starring anyone of any color in
the best picture nominations like so
there's a movie in there that I've gone
after several times and I love going
after which is Brooklyn uh-oh what about
Brooklyn is not the greatest movie ever
made its it's not it's it's just Oscar
bait yeah and and it's very you know I
watched it and I thought it was fine I
like fine you know when you're given
screeners you don't really it's like ahh
let's just see what this is and Oh
Brooklyn and oh she's torn from between
enough Brooklyn yeah I mean bridge of
spies is British spies was it makes good
what a fraud yeah exactly it does it
didn't you didn't walk away bridge rise
going man it was amazing use an okay
story I mean yeah look you've got you've
got Tom Hanks and stuff but they're all
great so they got they could take a
mediocre script and make it very fair
yeah but then I looked at what bothered
me was then like concussion is I didn't
see that that you should see as a
football fan is it good it's good I
think it's a good movie and I think how
they they go after the NFL and they
bought ad time during football games
that's a mover and put they didn't they
didn't pull their punches now I went
after the enemy I did I think they did I
mean anyone who's like oh they went soft
in the NFL Mike I don't know how I mean
they basically showed the NFL covering
it up knew about this disease tried to
stonewall CT yeah they try to stonewall
Will Smith's that dr. hit the character
he played the actual guy who discovered
the CTE disease and I'm like I'm gonna
see it now I for some reason Will Smith
doesn't like when I hear his name like
yeah you think big-budget action yeah
budget [ __ ] but this is a good one
huh I think it's good and it's like to
me that should have got a nomination
over Brooklyn or bridge of spies yeah
now why didn't concussion get a
nomination any thoughts you think black
there's no I believe I mean people in it
I mean they did somebody put it like
they found this statistic on the inner I
don't know how accurate is but they were
basically looking at all the nominations
over the years and it's like black
people get nominated when they're like
in a lower position and they struggle to
but when black people are like what
years a slave yep when their position of
authority they don't get nominate know
when a white guys in a position of
authority and he does something then he
it's all old white guys who run the
[ __ ] academy right imagine and white
women mostly white rice and and and then
probably younger Academy voters that
just don't vote or they just get their
ballot Nicole Brooklyn sounds good I saw
the poster it's she has an accent so I'm
sure it's wonderful you know but you
gotta know there's got to be
some young voters in there cuz Mad Max
got a nomination for best picture which
i did is warranted did do you I I
thought it was I thought George Miller
did was amazing and basic everybody says
that except I I came out against madman
I I don't know it might have been you
know how sometimes you see a movie and
you're just like you shouldn't have seen
a movie that night because of whatever's
going on in your life I had just
finished like a three and again this is
gonna sound like I'm coming at you
Graham and I'm coming at the audience
but I had just finished it I think it
was three week running Soho Theatre in
London one-man show anyway I had
finished it that night and I was just
walking around in the days I was like so
[ __ ] tired and I and I wanted
everybody was talking about Mad Max I
saw it in London and I just thought that
it was so like hyper violent like so
hyper and it never stopped from this
reward anna and i just what's it into
that that night i think i was in more of
a Brooklyn like oh she's on a ferry oh
and also I thought it was funny that
there was a guy strapped to a truck
played a guitar that cracked me up but
what but everybody did talk about how
George Miller was it just like one shot
or there was I mean all the practical
effects in there which I mean in this
way you're talking about cinematography
I'm talking about not only about cinema
Tyrese oh I'm talking about how you told
the story a compelling story with very
little dialogue it was very little you
told it with expressions you told it
with you know you got a little bit of
backstory in there I mean I thought I
was to watch it again because everybody
I know likes it and this is so funny i
tweeted that I thought it was the Royal
I said because I like to get a rise out
of the Twitter community and I kid my
people on twitter / iya hahahahaha I
said I thought Mad Max was a bunch of
steroidal violence that had you know and
then they would cut to like you know
those women who were trying to get
pregnant like and all of a sudden it be
like ah it's the four women or three
women whatever right in the back of the
Huck looking in jelly I got people came
at me it was hilarious yeah that's
always fun you [ __ ] [ __ ] it was a
great movie Pepitone fine yeah like
people work they never really go apple I
like that movie do because basically
it's showing that you know men have
destroyed society it'sit's you had the
bullet people the oil people in the
water people and it's all controlled and
how women are gonna have to save us
that's when so you I should watch it
again i would i would this time don't
after you've done a three run in London
Wow whatever anyway I was shooting a
movie in Tokyo and I just decided I said
to myself after you know it's a great
Tokyo movie you probably heard of it
it's called walking on why with Philippe
Petit anyway um not the documentary but
Anna I just wandered into revenant was
hidden for revenant I was tired from
planning the 4th annual los angeles
podcast festival era podcast.com tickets
i'm sure soon and I decided that
spotlight would be just the right touch
of movie does everything is just a
hidden plug I only have a couple minutes
or so name a couple of more good movie
you know what movie I just watched on a
screener that was actually I just got
into it too it was Carol I've heard good
things about that movie and I actually
it's gotten some nominations that I want
to watch it because it's got two actors
actresses that I really like yeah and
they and it's hot like yeah they're into
they're in love with you it's hot but
done in a very tasteful way which is
what I'm into like extremely tasteful
female-on-female love that that is what
I have always been about look not you
know like hardcore stuff but just like
very tastefully faithfully smoldering
you know a yearning that don't stay with
me this is also going to relate to reven
it in a second just a taste so Karen
soap was no way now did Carol have a
bear was there a Barrett Carol I forget
no but that was a good [ __ ]
Louise that was I heard and I heard it's
actually I heard it's really subtle
really cool I thinking which I like um
you know trumbo's good Trumbo now I
gotta say yes I want to talk about a
couple political films to him thank God
they made a couple really good political
films this year and I gotta give credit
to adam mckay on [ __ ] the big short
man did you like did you see the picture
i did like the big table I loved the big
short i haven't heard people raving
about it but i thought it really punched
the wall street guys in the face like I
thought it was so far I thought it was
so far the best movie to say here's with
these [ __ ] they're such [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that's the thing like I
know just I can't let it go the
struggling like Trump is a part of this
evil thing yeah i mean honestly you want
to call it what i mean the two-party
system I mean yeah Bush gave seven
hundred billion dollars bail amount
Obama gave seven hundred billion dollars
the Alamo yeah let's one point that's
why I'm a Bernie guy because I don't
consider him part of the Democratic
machine which is probably why he's not
gonna get elected but you never know I
know you if all the Bernie supporters
because here's the thing like it's how
one of the reasons Obama got reelected
in 2012 the Republicans were doing
standard they were calling people on
home phones and polling and Obama was
like hey people you know under 40 under
30 vote by mail oh yeah and people were
like oh this is easy in this era of apps
and uber and we do that yeah I don't
even know the vote by mail sign up for
vote by mail I start doing it years ago
cuz I'm on the road how cool as much as
I personally like this are you still in
the road a lot man not as much as I was
because doing them doing the I was
worried about you just always on the
road it was no I get [ __ ] tired
quickly I was getting a little burnt um
2015 actually was the year I was I was
the least on the road since 2000 that
feel good it felt great I stayed home a
lot to finish the documentary and and it
was like it was really cuz when i was
doing that 40 weeks a year you know that
your home for two days three days I back
out again at anything 40 weeks a year
but close I bet that I just get like I
it [ __ ] with your head I don't know any
physically mentally like
it's a [ __ ] in torrance thing I was
starting then you have to be funny on
top yeah I mean the thing it was like
that I was like I'll people how was I go
I love the show was yeah you know I did
some cool things in this town or that
town I saw some old friends oh yeah what
the [ __ ] rental car shuttle bus and
the baggage claim and the humping around
and oh you know it's just like oh you
know I I'm but you know i'm not i'm not
buying first-class tickets all right but
I fly a lot so I try to get you some
time to get upgraded you don't get that
upgrade and there's some [ __ ] next to
you with his [ __ ] cabbage or whatever
brought on you've had two hours sleep
and your last night show closed and
you're just like wow that's rough man at
least I got a layover and ravleen like
at that level where we're like traveling
salesman who have like briefcase of
textiles say yes going from town to town
yeah Willy [ __ ] logo I know I've said
that like because I yeah I was like I
you know I sell merch after especially
when I was opening up for Doug Benson
like I needed the merch sales to make up
right to get it close to headline money
to I could pay my bills right and you
know it was cool and fans del get and
there was some there's some cool a
spectable lots of her psyche i'm a
[ __ ] Willy Loman of comedy I'm just
like Willie love it yeah you know i'm
just like slugging it out and and there
was some really cool things you know and
now in this day and age it's different
than when we started you can build a fan
base and people you know they'll pull
out their phone and follow you right
there on the spot when you're being
funny on stage or whatever they take the
photos at and that's all great but i was
starting to get burnt and like i was
like i'm sick of my act I was like
that's true too and I never realized
that but when you're on the road you
tend to [ __ ] and I don't like this
like you tend to [ __ ] lean on your
material that you know works you know
what I mean instead of like really
[ __ ] around well sometimes and this
is the thing I was the funnest part
anyway to stand it's the funnest part of
doing standard do that a lot I like that
I wasn't doing it as much yeah no I get
it because here's why I think because
you're tired you've had five hours
you're sleepy so two planes to get there
you barely had enough time to shower and
then you're eating some how you
improvise and I'm just supposed to riff
like sorry man I gotta do my act I hurt
my back in Montreal just like I had been
on the road for I want and I [ __ ]
tweaked my back and it I was icing my
back in between sets and I was not
riffing I was wrong i was going toward
this bit this vamp is and i know they
work and you have a good show yeah and
maybe someone yell something out and you
get some riffing there but like the last
couple times I I took a couple weeks off
over the holidays and stuff and actually
went on a vacation and over the holidays
that's nice and it was like the last
I've done three shows since the the
holidays and they were all headline sets
and I [ __ ] rift for a half of them
and it was just like aah crash yes fresh
I'm finding new material and Mike right
the riff from last night now I'm gonna
try that again tonight maybe I can
actually put that into the act and like
it was yeah it was exciting yeah I got
kind of reborn from it a little
absolutely you need to take breaks from
this you gotta man it's like anything
yeah yeah like anything well let's uh
let's wrap up man thank you for coming
what do you want to promote some of your
website some your uh whatever well yeah
the comedy film nerds podcast you can go
to comedy films com or an itunes we go
to itunes com CFN um we do a weekly
movie review podcast we sometimes we
released two episodes will do a spoiler
app like we do have a kung fu panda's
boiler up coming out this week uh no you
do yeah with Chris's daughter oh so uh
and then was it good I actually liked it
I liked the first one I thought the
second one went off track as far as like
the thing that was good about the first
one that the third one captured it had
these really great sentiments of what
kung fu truly is not about kicking ass
it's about unlocking the best part of
you yeah and also they do do that yeah
so it's really it's really cool the
second one just was the mmm yeah but the
third one kind of comes back to that and
how you can be a teacher and and finding
your everyone has a strange just off the
topic for a second did you see that just
accuse Pixar about the emotions inside
kids what was that called again Oh
inside out how is that as a good really
good to really good move at its nominate
and I should have been the voice of
anger but they gave it a lewis black
it's like go [ __ ] your right well
anything only one whole [ __ ] uh yeah I
by the way I love Pete pizza yeah pizza
Co great guys good guys uh you know uh
you know what I'm saying good I yeah my
twitter handle is at grandma would i'm
at grandma with an Instagram grandma
Wacom's my website facebook at all my
tour dates waiting instagram i actually
i got in about a year ago I can't like
it I kind of liked the format how it's
really it's visual yeah you could just
like snap a shot it's it's sort of a
different i get addicted to all of these
things though like like once i start
take it like like I'll if I tweet
something funny and then I do an
Instagram thing i'm always going how
many likes how many likes on this thing
I just I just posted i go i know this is
brilliant you don't [ __ ] like the
head and go to the side of goddamn p I
just post it I just post it i turn on my
apple TV and i just say [ __ ] guys I
[ __ ] I'm canceling my [ __ ] cable
not watching you know honey this is all
the Opus a message you know he said that
google it for me alright well thanks for
listening to pep talks thank you grandma
elwood pep talks on all things comedy
network for all my show updates follow
me on twitter at Eddie Pepitone and you
can follow Graeme already set it at
Graham Elwood which is let me spell if
you gr aah AME L would and at comedy
film there's icon send me an email if
you're enjoying the show that's why I
don't get any eep epitome @
sbcglobal.net and rate us on iTunes and
thanks and we'll see you next week sweet
sweet sweet
sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet
sweet sweet sweet